the left's racial grievance narrative is
false that's why we want it out of the
classroom not because we're afraid of
our history because it's just
patently absurd here's the
most preposterous example of it in
recent days colin kaepernick
you know the whiny former football
player who cashed in on racial grievance
and made a gazillion dollars doing it
colin kaepernick has a movie out that
opens up on him comparing
playing in the national football league
to being
a chattel slave
what they don't want you to understand
is what's being established
is a power dynamic
before they put you on the field
teams poke
pride and examine you
searching for any defect that might
affect your performance no boundary
respected
no dignity left intact
come on boys
[Applause]
look at that shape there look at this
mr farmer i got your bid 30. james 30 to
you 100. so
next we're coming up best one we got
500
600.
look at this here
come on who wants this
700.
there we go now what the
1 000.
i'm telling you what i want y'all
okay so you see all these football
players transformed into chattel slaves
in the antebellum south
and the nfl they're just like the slave
owners
slave auctions
brings up a pretty basic question
if the nfl is like a an antebellum slave
plantation
why has colin kaepernick spent the last
six seven years
begging them to take him back
if the nfl is slavery
then why is colin kaepernick been
begging to be a slave and whining when
they don't want to enslave him
did did slaves in the antebellum south
did they have multi-million dollar
contracts did they spend their whole
lives training and just trying desperate
to be
slaves on some plantation
i don't i don't think so
now what's funny colin kaepernick opens
up the the movie and he's dressed like
this sort of clown version of malcolm x
you know like mark's observed
history repeats itself first first is
tragedy then is farce we're in the farce
portion of this sort of thing what what
colin kaepernick is observing
is that
in for slaves
and for football players
the the primary thing that matters is
your physical
health
right you need for
for football players they're really it's
a primarily physical job there's a
little mental aspect to it too a little
bit of strategy but it's mostly you just
got to be big and strong and fast and
tough and well coordinated
and so i guess that's true
for physical laborers who were slaves i
guess that's true for
all sorts of physical laborers
colin kaepernick's very offended by this
athletics is about physical excellence
okay and unfortunately colin kaepernick
was not sufficiently excellent to
remain in the football league for very
long
fine not ever not everyone is very very
few people are if colin kaepernick is
upset that he he didn't pursue a more
intellectual field
you know it maybe he he he regrets being
having a physical career he wishes that
he were a paper pusher or something or
he had a desk job well okay
then he should have spent his life
cultivating it cultivating his intellect
i guess but he certainly
he certainly hasn't done
that there are many football players who
are pretty intellectual actually colin
kaepernick is not
not one of them i'm glad you like that
clip i liked it too if you want more of
them subscribe ring the bell more
importantly than that though because
sometimes
our friends on some of these platforms
don't send notifications head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
we'll see you there
[Music]
[Music]
you